so anyway um yeah my girl has me
nothing nothing so I like your girl and
I like what she's doing for you she's
wonderful it is hard to say you know cuz
she's like the [ __ ] at what she does and
then I had to lose weight for this thing
and she's like do you want me to help
you cuz we had just started dating she
knows her [ __ ] or that she knows her
[ __ ] but it means that I have to respect
what the [ __ ] she's saying about the
[ __ ] that she's doing well something
else because I can't be like come on I'm
gonna eat this she'll be like okay fine
go ahead but I'm not gonna help
well the promises that vitro doesn't
really work you got to do something else
when it comes to anything 80 in life you
have a compulsion for which we all have
I think all of us if you don't have some
kind of addiction of some kind you're
probably a bore yeah he does create him
cats cats cat loves huge very much color
black guys and you like food now hey I
got nothing
look kidding good mileage here what's
your addiction do you have a thing mmm
probably eating I eat like an [ __ ] oh
you do okay so a lot of best right
Heating has a lot of yeah I know you go
through that sometimes it's just if you
eat yourself to death at night it's not
unlike being [ __ ] drunk yes you're
releasing all those endorphins for me
you know look let's not get into it uh
sure
clinical depression can lead to some bad
choices huh when you're eating late at
night sure yeah what is your go-to food
when you're binging if I'm eat now I
don't do this anymore yeah and if you
within the sound of my voice maybe you
are doing this maybe this is something
you're doing right black people you
helped in this podcast yeah oh sure um
it's oh it's a problem when it's late at
night and let's say again I'm not doing
this anymore also because I I'm trying
to lose weight for another thing and I'm
kind of on lockdown remember when we
were on the 10-minute podcast that I
used when we were on remember when we
did the ten minute remember when we were
yeah remember we did the 10 minute
podcast I used to invite people that in
in public to just come up and thumb my
calves yes and just get into him need
him like dough yeah
a new challenge if you see me eating the
cheeseburger yeah kick it out of my
[ __ ] hand Jesus Christ yeah I don't
give a [ __ ]
now care if you want to know why I'm
saying that why oh that ol actually only
goes for the year 2019 yeah don't fits
after that if it's you're having to
listen to this podcast in 2031 yeah
please don't kick me while I'm sitting
there probably with because well might
kill you might scalp here he'll pull you
he's been known to grab a man's hair and
pull it right off his head I'll turn you
into a [ __ ] burger and by then it'll
be Trump's martial law and you know
that's right they'll be MIT there won't
be many ways to punish a white guy for
turning anyone into a [ __ ] hamburger
right you want to think you think we
were [ __ ] to trees wait until 2031
I'm writing a book about it oh man so so
anyway she's got me on lockdown so I
don't [ __ ] eat anything but before
that one thing I would do it'll be late
at night you know it's [ __ ] Saturday
you know and maybe maybe I'm just gonna
chill out
maybe I'm just gonna stay at home sure
maybe watch a movie shoot maybe I'd have
a hoot or two of marijuana yeah I don't
normally talk about that sort of thing
that's a queer being very honest yeah I
don't drink alcohol right and I a little
weed goes a long way a little just a
little bit nothing like that and I and
I'm from British Columbia where there's
weed aplenty and couldn't wheat very
good weed and I didn't even really touch
the [ __ ] until I was almost 40 so kids
don't smoke weed but uh oh the [ __ ]
the the the emotional eatin polar bear
just had a little bit of weed oh yeah
and it's late at night and we're
watching wrestling yeah that now about
to get so now you're watching wrestling
late at night yep and you got now as
weed does we accentuate your depression
no or doesn't but it just does mosey
almost hungry well yeah perhaps if I
smoke a bunch of weed then maybe they
otherwise little weed makes you feel I'm
feeling great and and by the way when
you're feeling great you're relaxed why
not treat yourself treat yourself
that's all you know what we're trying to
do good things so we're gonna eat
healthy foods yeah we're gonna order
we're not gonna order a pizza
now we're gonna fool ourselves and order
Thai food because what you could do when
you order from a Thai
food restaurant is order healthy things
yeah you know you could get some oh one
of the things I like to get from Thai
restaurants is Morning Glory
it's just sauteed watercress with garlic
no big deal
what if you just got that and some brown
rice right yeah let me take that big 15
pound [ __ ] in the night be ready for
that intruder
yeah but not will sasso no sure he gets
the Morning Glory sure he gets the brown
rice I've diet coke with that that no so
we got a gateway we got a gateway yeah
now you can stop there oh sorry is there
anything else you'd like me order how
about some don't please accent yeah
that's a good accent yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay uh my only friends who do type my
only white friends who do Thai accents
are my friends Yohan and Cyrus the
Sheila chip brothers the Walter White
and Jesse Pinkman is she legit because
they were there for they both have Asian
wives but they were there for living
there for like over ten years and I
thank speak fluent I does that allow it
trend more time to ask some of the
nomads Asian I can say I trained more
time so I can tell you it's a lot i
train more time for years because some
guys some guys in the US see when they
roundhouse when they'll kick like legs
okay that their their corner will go by
and why it Miller somebody met this guy
was there it said the mayhem Ella got in
the fight was like literally ten dudes
in some in Florida Miami and they were
all like these giant roid heads and they
didn't know who they were [ __ ] with
and mayhem was dancing with a girl woman
and the guy goes hey bro get the [ __ ]
out of here it goes to try to punch
mayhem mayhem knows he steps out just
because I I'm getting [ __ ] crazy guys
face down on his knee
and his friend said that mayhem was out
in the street and he was just going oh I
just throw elbows those guys are coming
and hit him and smiling alright and
there was a body's there was like a
mountain of bodies all around him he was
just literally out of a movie like you
[ __ ] with mayhem Miller you [ __ ]
big muscular roid heads Pele had no idea
and they beat up like literally a gang
of dudes like a gang of guys just that
kept coming he just by Nathan Miller
smiles when he fights oh he's the best
I missed that bus again i dude where's
Ethan I don't know I think probably a
few blocks from here
so we get some Thai food there's mayhem
[ __ ] love it we get some Thai food
right we meaning me and how about some
pad wound scent right oh it's just rice
it's just rice noodles with some egg
some chicken well that rice noodle is
[ __ ] just straight rights gluten you
think oh it's good for you because it's
rice and then you know let's try the
fish balls and maybe some chicken larb
[ __ ] make it pork larb and let me get
the chicken wings and that's it so we
got about 8,000 calories okay
so that's that's gonna be good for an
11:00 p.m. meal won't finish you're
gonna finish all of all of it okay I'm
getting even the little parts of noodles
that have broken off and are in the
[ __ ] yeah the tin I saw you eat 24
chicken wings
did you bones at all because you were
talking and you you were you were you
were gonna come home hungry and I was
like he's he's crunching just the wing
part if it's I could bribe right you ate
all of it you ever know bones left you
can't eat the flat you can't eat the two
little bones now the tibia and the
fibula bring up bring up when those
hyenas or that and those animals drag
the antelope into the into that African
hotel in the lobby
take a look at this these these hyenas
chase down a kudu
or something in a hell that's an
aggregate and
they had at it in the lobby of this
5-star resort and you might want to see
might want a [ __ ] mess is it the one
that Bo I don't know is that the one
that says bloody mess now normally I'd
[ __ ] on Brian for interrupting my story
with that story about wild animals while
I'm trying to talk about being a fat guy
ordering food you know I want to get
back this is really interesting yeah so
this is this is what you're what yeah
following via Bezos may have set set and
you realize the this is good oh here
they are
because there was a big commotion
there's a lot of line oh [ __ ] yeah guys
walking around barefoot there's [ __ ]
Rhino [ __ ] don't worry about it alright
now everybody's got guns
and there you go well here's the here's
the Lariat go oh that's what happens
when hyenas ah no I mean oh they they
ate the face off the [ __ ] oh yeah
they didn't get a chance to really get
enough of it but yeah [ __ ] please like
they go they went to its organs yeah
that's where the only difference in that
video is if you had had that could who
there would be nothing left if it would
probably be nothing left what would be
let clean a blood and you know what I'll
tell you this much we're shooting the
Grizzlies up in the Arctic you'd be
having Stu you on set you know late
second meal and you'd go around towards
the bottom of the [ __ ] caribou Stu
yeah with the ladle and you'd pull up no
[ __ ] [ __ ] antler I'd be like why the
[ __ ] not there's marrow in there so
absolutely I'll fry those I'll fry those
antlers down yep ty chicken wing style
yeah and I'll eat them so that's fine
right that's that that's what we've
that's what we've done well a little bit
later they really did [ __ ] up that that
poor everything's dead a little bit
later maybe you want something sweet
well where I live in Los Feliz there's
all sorts of like [ __ ] you know
creameries open late at night oh no so
you've got 8,000 calories now now we got
to get some dessert and maybe get some
maybe get some dessert yeah or [ __ ] it
let's just let's just post mates
7-eleven that way we'll get just it
we'll get some [ __ ] talking about
haagen-dazs ice cream that's right there
you gotta hit the little cups yeah yeah
but they only come what little cup so
it's too hard to order get the [ __ ]
thing I won't need it all
and then maybe just you know [ __ ] it
maybe do a Twix no KitKat I'll get both
no no just the Kit Kat and the Snickers
no twigs and the flakes and then and
maybe but I want something salty with
that so maybe some potato chips it's a
lot I also like those Fritos chips those
chili and cheese Fritos chili cheese
those are really good so let's get both
of them those and I think that's it
gummy bears and then so we'll get that
and then now we're really [ __ ] now
we're laying on the couch and we're
watching you know we're watching NXT you
know shout out to Kyle O'Reilly and the
undisputed era and you know we're and
then we're good right yeah we're good
we're good but now we're [ __ ] we've
had a little bit of marijuana we ate
some Thai food we had a little more uh
yeah we had some sweets yeah so now we
go to bed right it's 4:00 in the morning
yeah so we got to get to bed now you
texting Saturday night yeah we have a
thing me Will Sasso Marshall Cooke and
Chris D'Elia have a text thread that's
been going for years I see and and we
it's called guys gee I think right now
it's just called [ __ ] yeah it's called
[ __ ] and we it's usually called guys
and we and basically we'll we have this
thing where a world never sleeps well
wait Chris whatever texts just Chris
could be up really early going you know
coming back from a flight from somewhere
he could be up really late cuz he likes
to stay up late but usually only till
around - yeah or something like that but
it doesn't matter when he texts I text
back and Chris says hey will
it detects that hey will why are you
simply always away yeah that's right
11:30 a.m. this Y are you awake cuz York
because 4 a.m. your waist 8 p.m. you
wake 6:30 a.m. you wish marijuana
food yeah cuz marijuana well I just love
my keep odd hours but back a little
while ago it could have been that yeah
it would have been that his marijuana
slash food and and and depression now
now is now you had your sweets and had a
little more marijuana that's a lot of
food with yet gummy bears we got we got
potato chips we got that tub of
haagen-dazs we got Twizzlers yeah it
works we got a kick
yeah we get out we so now we're now
we're good yeah
only we're not because maybe we had a
little bit more weed and we're watching
some really interesting rest but surely
you're watching takeover Brooklyn
and we're like surely your sofa they
done with osku since she left NXT
nothing they should have kept that
[ __ ] winning streak going yeah
and you know we're just what we're
watching a Velveteen dream the dude is
so [ __ ] over yeah right melt
Velveteen dream versus Matt riddle
you saw that sure did I mean [ __ ]
riddle pull they beat the [ __ ] out of a
half-hour and [ __ ] velvetine still
pulls it out on believe that's a
character he simply the [ __ ] yeah you
know that a simply this year he's the
[ __ ] so then then it's like okay well
now it's getting early yeah so maybe
I'll just stay up a little bit let's get
some breakfast but hold on yeah but
let's get some breakfast I know but you
just had so much oh what's the only
thing that's open for breakfast
McDonald's oh good call but there's also
Denny's which is more healthy than
McDonald's because you can sit down in
it oh you can also sit down at
McDonald's mm-hmm
toss it up let's do Denny's today it's
never been more than three I'd like to
embellish in the story and say that I
had also ordered McDonald's now but I
have ordered from three different things
in one evening so crap yeah that's
really bad that's that's a real food
addiction yeah that was a binge yeah
that's a binge now food addiction you
have a way cuz I'm going through therapy
yeah and I find it me too gotta stay in
it
you gotta stand it because my therapist
speaking of any kind of compulsion or
when you want to do something that
you're not supposed to whatever it might
be there will be this idea of having a
relationship with your shadow side with
the side of yourself not even trying to
fix it but just just have a relationship
with that guy who maybe isn't who you
should be all the time you understand I
think all of us have I think all of us
are who we were
who we are who we could be and we also
have in my opinion two [ __ ] sides to
our personality we got the light and we
got the dark we got the we got good old
Bry and then we got shadow Brian yeah
guys will there's and I think all of us
have that don't we
no Brian parts of our personality sure
most of the time yeah friendly polar
bear yep but then occasionally I'm that
brown black colossal grizzly yeah who
eats humans I'll eat the Thai restaurant
you'll eat legs first too
yeah and okay so do you have a way of
[ __ ] eat your antlers do you have a
way of helping other people have this
food yeah tomorrow's a new day you know
uh get up don't hate yourself it's the
hardest thing in the world to love
yourself right yeah well it's not the
heart is yeah no I don't think the human
beings are programmed to love themselves
all the time when they do that's called
social maybe maybe yeah I mean by the
way maybe loving yourself isn't so good
for you because what drives you a lot of
times is the need to compensate for a
shortcoming in my opinion there's an to
explain what well if you love yourself a
lot you'd be a smiling puppy yeah you'd
be [ __ ] up and you're gonna be there's
gonna be bad days and you're not gonna
be able to explain them and I don't
think our puny human minds can't so just
a [ __ ] go I'm having a bad day
did you order some Thai food you [ __ ]
up enjoy the [ __ ] out of it enjoy every
[ __ ] bite right and then tomorrow
wake up and you know maybe write
something down see what it is you want
to do for the week yeah maybe for the
month because I'll forget I'll go oh I'm
eating right I'm doing and doing it good
and then a few days ago by a girl what
happened to that thing I was doing
anyway
diet food McDonald's but let me let me
piggyback on that because the other
thing I think is people always try to
when they set goals and they look at the
top of the mountain I gotta lose all his
weight or I gotta I gotta get busy and I
gotta get my real estate license I know
hold on hold on just try doing one tiny
thing every day like I actually believe
in in consistency and I'm talking about
read one page people say you wanna get
into real estate read one page of a book
that's it why
five minutes of of a guy who talking
about real estate on YouTube I mean one
tiny little thing every day
tiny five minutes eat one less chicken
wing one less chicken just one less
chicken wing you could order more just
to eat one less sure you're up a net
more yeah let's say you ordered ten yeah
but you ate them all the next time order
20 and eat 19 I'm joking of course
all I'm yeah that doesn't really work no
I would say wake up and [ __ ] try to
go for a goddamn walk do one go do some
moves and one [ __ ] I don't have your
[ __ ] answers all I know is that
everybody [ __ ] deals with [ __ ]
you might be looking at me and going hey
Will Sasso I enjoyed you in the
Grizzlies and I can't wait to drive to
the United States to watch American
movie maybe you're on the phone woman
remotely not American we've gotta say it
right yeah I know yeah I got that movie
with that [ __ ] long haired Christina
Hendricks should have been starring
Bryan Callen yeah but he was busy yeah I
don't know what you guys would have
pulled off I can do anything I don't
know I could yeah but I don't know I
love it anything that was necessary of
the I'm as good an actor as anybody's
ever left Keep Calm okay and you're
saying hey I'm gonna soldier in south to
watch American woman and I think you're
great well I like your hat and your
stories and your cover of Luckenbach
Texas by Waylon Jennings and I'm over
here going oh I'm a fat sack of [ __ ]
because I just ate fish balls
fried fish balls from the Thai place and
I'll chase it with some [ __ ] more
steel head or a steel head and innovate
in nunavut right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue Oh what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]